[Musik]
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei anleihen video ich hoffe natürlich
geht es gut ich glaube das ist fast das
erste video wo ich einfach so komplett
aussehe wie ich aussehe wenn ich meine
haare nicht mache ja so sieht es gerade
aus um die sind wieder relativ lang
geworden und ich bin letztens auf die
idee gekommen wenn ich das nächste mal
zum friseur gehe dieses video zu machen
ich bin wirklich gespannt wie das wird
weil ich habe bis jetzt halt hier in
köln eigentlich ja so ein leichtes stamm
friseur bei dem bin ich auch eher selten
sondern bei meinen eltern zu hause habe
ich halt so ein friseur wo ich hingehe
ich bin ich auch zufrieden und so
wirklich bei anderen friseurläden bin
ich noch nie in meinem ganzen leben
gewesen
ich weiß nicht ob ihr die videos von mir
gesehen habt und zwar ging es einmal um
das schlechteste restaurant in ganz köln
und das ging um den schlechtesten
bürgerladen also der war wirklich
grausam habe ich halt alles bei google
rausgesucht mit die rezension
durchgelesen und ja ich bin halt auf die
idee kommen macht das gleiche doch auch
mal in einer anderen branche und zwar
nicht nur in der gastronomie die bürger
und so weiter sondern ja wir fahren wir
zum versager ich habe wirklich lange
gesucht und bin fündig geworden ja das
cool ist der friseurladen ist gar nicht
mal so weit weg von mir und ich hoffe
ich kann auch einfach hingehen ohne
termin wie immer bevor es losgeht
schauen wir uns erstmal die rezensionen
zusammen an das ding hat insgesamt 2,5
sterne wertung war wirklich das
schlechteste in köln die meisten dann
wirklich irgendwas zwischen 4,5 und 5
sterne ich meine ich stellte mir auch
ziemlich schwierig vor so viele leute
unzufrieden nach hause zu schicken dass
die allen rezension schreiben und einem
stern geben so leute also dass in die
rezension zum laden wir haben insgesamt
27 stück das ist jetzt nicht mehr viel
aber ist auch nicht wenig und wir fangen
an mit der ersten hier sehr unfreundlich
ich habe einen gutschein gut das lassen
wir jetzt mal weg gutschein blablabla
dann wird der gutschein nicht eingelöst
ok einfach finger weg hier und
professional eigentlich heißt es
unprofessioneller lieber akh und
professionelle friseur chef der seine
angebote und worte nicht teilt dazu noch
muss man hierfür kleinigkeiten einen tag
urlaub nehmen weil alles so lange dauert
und alles wieder korrigiert werden muss
die guten mitarbeiter haben alle
gekündigt hatte einen termin aber laden
geschlossen
keine nachricht keinen aushang an der
tür so was nennt sich promi und wie tief
was aber wenn ich ja genau richtig hier
heute probleme also soll anscheinend ein
promi und wie ein
was bin sehr enttäuscht als im laden an
kamen bekamen wir gleich den streits
zwischen dem chef und einem mitarbeiter
mit wurden als einzige kunde im laden
kaum beachtet dann wurden mir die haare
geschnitten mit der maschine wohlgemerkt
obwohl man bei einem spezialisten ein
scherenschnitt erwarten könnte er hier
gibt fünf sterne ich hatte einen sehr
netten haircut gemacht ich hatte einen
sehr nette herr cup gemacht genau genau
absolut nicht zu empfehlen als wäre ich
unter den rasen hergekommen super
stylist sehr gute kundenberatung und
betreuung vor allem mit bart hier nur
noch dorthin und hier dann zum beispiel
auch fünf sterne rezensionen gleich drei
unterländer mega geniale laden
sympathisch und relaxte mitarbeiter
superstimmung geniale beratung einlaufen
jeher also das finde ich hier wirklich
ein bisschen komisch es gibt nur
rezensionen entweder einstellen oder
fünf sterne so leute also ich würde
sagen ich drehe mich jetzt gleich mal
kurz vor der kamera und zeigt euch wie
meine haare jetzt aussehen und dann
haben wir später im vergleich und dann
hoffe ich dass ich da ohne termin hin
kann ich würde uns erst mal anrufen und
ja mal sehen was meine haaren wird
das durch muss es gerade noch die marie
beck bringt zum ball und dann geht es
besser
was würdest du denn sagen wir so ich
meine haare machen einen seitenblick
härter ob wie von millimetern und heiße
ich da nicht ich habe ja sechs aber es
ist ja relativ kalt deswegen würde ich
sagen machen heute macht ja aber macht
wieder so ein übergang also dass die
hier noch ein kleines bisschen länger
ist also ja gerade herausgefunden das
ist wohl ein wie star friseur
da sollte das ja wohl können also ich
bin wirklich gespannt weil das ding ist
der hat die schlechte bewertung in köln
und stellt sich als wie ip und dafür so
hin das ist ja eh gar nicht zusammen ja
auf jeden fall hier kürzer und dann hier
so ein bisschen länger oben lang lassen
sich sogar bis jetzt habe ich den kann
ich nicht will ich nicht - weshalb zu
nehmen obwohl die eigentlich günstig ist
ja übrigens auch nicht habe ich eben
noch raus bekommen
bis gleich so warte jetzt habe ich
gerade ein parkplatz gefunden er zurück
im friseur ich habe früher mal gewohnt
in der umgebung deswegen kann ich mich
sogar auch das problem ist ich habe kein
parkticket gezogen weil ich kein
kleingeld dabei hat das muss ich mich
erstmal muss ich noch strafe zweiten vor
mir habe ich hab den laden grad schon
gesehen dass er eigentlich recht gut aus
deswegen nicht verwundert nur hier ist
der laden
[Musik]
das geht vielleicht fragen sie erst mal
probieren und wenn ich dann bei hallo
ich musste einmal haare schneiden
ja es geht nicht heute wahrscheinlich
gar nicht mehr dann alles klar
das passt sich aber danke leider haben
die keinen termin mehrheit gehabt hat er
zumindest gesagt aber gar nicht mal
schlecht aus die konten nicht so gut
deutsch aber das ja gar kein problem
also waren schon dazu aber ich gehe
natürlich nicht auf ich gehe dann jetzt
zum anderen schlechten ich habe nämlich
noch ein solche ich bin jetzt zurück im
auto ich habe gerade noch ein bisschen
gesucht und hier in der nähe 400 meter
von hier ist noch einer der sogar noch
schlechter ist dann habe ich vorher gar
nicht gefunden
der hat ein halb stern herunter steht
auch direkt eine super rezension runter
und zwar der menschen raum und die
schlechten bewertungen hätten mich waren
sollen die besitzern hat mich zum weinen
gebracht ich bin euch das mal hier ein
und ich bin jetzt schon extra hier
hingefahren deswegen ich wollte schon
aufgeben weil der andere war wieder so
ewig weit weg aber da gehe ich jetzt
noch hin
und ja dann habe ich mal die machen
meine haare wieder schön oder halt auch
nicht
machen sie auch ohne termin auch so
super wenn paar sekunden später einmal
oben einfach bisschen weniger und die
seiten so 8mm ja auch ein bisschen
wirtsleute ich gut fertig jetzt erstmals
zum auto ihr seht ihr meine hat obwohl
ihr seht meine herren wahrscheinlich
nicht auf jeden fall krasse story
erzähle ich euch gleich es war auf jeden
fall witzig
also ich habe keine ahnung ob ich meine
haare gerade gut finden sondern noch
nicht wo sich zu hause noch mal
analysieren ist auf jeden fall ziemlich
kurz wir sehen uns zu hause
so leute also ich würde euch jetzt erst
mal die haare zeigen wie sie der friseur
gemacht hat also ich habe jetzt nichts
daran geändert und ich zeige euch jetzt
schon wieder das aus hier vielleicht
noch einmal schnell vorher wo ich kann
nur das schlips mal schreibt gern mal
eure meinung dazu in die kommentare
findet ihr das gut oder nicht ich sehe
jetzt auf jeden fall noch mal selber
weil keine ahnung so ganz mein geschmack
ist es nicht so leute also zurück in
meinem zimmer ich habe dir selber ein
bisschen gerichtet ich habe keine ahnung
also so ganz zufrieden bin ich nicht
aber es ist okay ich meine was kann man
auch bei meinen haaren falsch machen
eigentlich gar nicht ihr könnt gerne in
die kommentare schreiben was ihr dazu
sagt von hinten aber jetzt kommen wir
noch kurz zu der story von dem friseur
ich selbst ich war kurz und wenn
trefflich bleibt auf jeden fall dran
also leute wieder zurück so dass wir
doch angefangen hat jetzt mit diesen
haaren machen sich sind schon echt
extrem kurt gut also eigentlich wollte
als erstes in diesen frisuren den ich
hier schon zuvor gefunden habe in diesem
star friseur das stand auch wirklich an
der tür dran wie ip und star friseur
traurig und den leuten die da drin saßen
kann ich jetzt keinen also ich glaube
das waren keine stars wir hatten leider
keinen termin mehr für mich aber drin
sonst echt cool aus also das war jetzt
auf keinen fall so dass man denkt okay
bisschen ranzig dann habe ich ja durch
zufall den anderen friseur noch auf
google maps gefunden der komischerweise
genau gegenüber von dem war und die
waren beide extrem schlecht bewerte ich
weiß nicht ob das an den leuten liegt
die da in der umgebung wohnen und dahin
gehen dass die alle sehr hohe ansprüche
haben keinen plan aber man muss sagen
der laden war eigentlich auch so
typische friseurladen ich hab's ja auch
ein bisschen aufgenommen die wände waren
zwar schon ein bisschen heruntergekommen
da will ich gar nicht meckern ich habe
mir mein haar statt 20 euro bezahlt was
für kölner verhältnisse okay sie ist das
immer ein bisschen teurer als auf dem
land da zu halten und meistens 12 13 14
jetzt so sorry das finde ich ganz witzig
weil egal in welchem laden ich sonst war
der nicht mein stamm laden ist war es
einfach immer so ich konnte den laden
rein da war eine mitarbeiterin fragt sie
ob die auch ohne termin machen die soja
setzt sich dahin
dann kam eine andere
noch dazu die man so hey was geht ich
dachte schon jetzt die haare und dann
sitze ich da so zwei minuten und
plötzlich ja ich habe absolut nichts
gegen schwule so kann ja jeder machen
was er möchte
aber bei mir ist es immer so egal in
welchem friseurladen ich gehe also hier
in köln zumindest mir schneidet immer
ein schwuler mann die haare das ist so
schwierig zu erklären ohne jetzt
irgendwie blöd rüberzukommen so ich habe
absolut nichts gegen solche menschen
kann jeder machen was er will aber er
kam halt so um die ecke so voll
plötzlich halt und das war keiner wo man
so denkt okay
ja vielleicht ist der schwul das war
wirklich einer da wusste man so ok der
ist stocks wohl und so ist ja auch mit
mir umgegangen
der meinte so schön haare schöne haben
dann hat er mir irgendwas davon erzählt
dass das ja jetzt im trend ist so bisher
mit anlage hat und so ich glaube ich
hatte das sogar auch ein bisschen
aufgenommen also das war wirklich echt
witzig ich habe keine ahnung warum wir
hier in köln immer homosexuelle männer
die haare schneiden wenn ich in irgend
einem friseursalon gehe aber ist auf
jeden fall immer ein lustiges gespräch
ich habe den laden gerade auch schon
eine positive bewertung gegeben ich
werde den laden hier jetzt nicht sein
weil dann kann man halt bei den vor und
nachnamen herausfinden so das hatte ich
jetzt die letzten beiden male muss nicht
sein aber war auf jeden fall wieder ganz
lustig hier können ja mal in die
kommentare schreiben worauf den noch
bock hätte und bewertet man eine neue
frisur
wir sehen uns übermorgen wieder gibt es
neues video freitag um 14 uhr